what is this place what damn it  a laboratory it is quite marvelous I now  find it now under I've seen so few  victims of the disease in here yeah you  see I thought you were incapable of  speech and somewhat startled you um can  oh my  yes götze I sent you prefer not to most  victims of the disease are quite  melancholy and do not react at all well  to conversation I have seen you several  times now and have not protected the  disease in you therefore wise Hume you  are also a doctor yes  actually uh call me but what disease are  you talking about why go doctor the  great pestilence what an exists all all  the plague should have seen that coming  but no one here is infected I can assure  you oh good doctor I can assure you the  pestilence is here and I can sense it it  is my duty in life to rid the world of  it  my cure is most effective your cure your  chores cost us hundreds of lives  your cure is faulty good doctor my cure  is most effective  you